am 20 juni solle es sich an der alfie an
einer 11 jährigen vergangen haben er
wurde nach der tat sofort von der
polizei gefasst kam am folgetag wegen
des schweren verdacht dann auch in
untersuchungshaft
doch am dritten juli 2020 also nur 13
tage nach der tat wurde der haftbefehl
auf antrag der staatsanwaltschaft völlig
überraschend und unter auflagen
ausgesetzt
der bereits polizeibekannte mann kam
also frei und darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit dem bild reporter dirk
decker der mir live zugeschaltet ist
dirk was kannst du uns über den
mutmaßlichen täter in diesen beiden
kindesmissbrauchsfällen sagen auf drei
jahre begrenzt er hat von diesem krieg
aus den man hier sieht das ist jedoch
unter dort stunde straße und in
kinderspielplatz der pool von dort aus
und von bekannten auch als sein revier
benutzt hat um seinen ohren zu verbieten
um diesem ort wurde ich angesprochen
50 meter weiter bis zum 10 rund 200 bar
in den ausschuss gegangen wo er dann
dieses junge mädchen missbraucht in der
von nur 13 tagen soll er zwei
minderjährige vergewaltigt haben
wie gehen jetzt also die weiteren
ermittlungen wie läuft das jetzt weiter
ist der momentanen haft wie soll es
jetzt weitergehen
zwei sitzt jetzt wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs
einheits mit vergewaltigung in ab
das macht ja auch voraussichtlich bis
prozessbeginn sein kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass erneute haftprüfung dazu
führen würde dass er wieder auf wiese
vorwürfe zwei kinder im alter von hilft
eine mädchen fahrzeug bis 12 13 jahren
vergewaltigt zu haben ist einfach zu
schwer wiegen als das man diesen fehler
wohl nochmal macht in österreich zu
entlassen vielen dank dirk decker und
darüber möchte ich jetzt auch sprechen
mit dem rechtsanwalt philipp hotspots
aris er ist mir nun live zugeschaltet
guten abend herr bizarres sagen sie mir
wir haben gerade schon darüber
gesprochen das ist eigentlich ein
skandal ein mann der ein elfjähriges
kind vergewaltigt wird dann freigelassen
weil er einen festen wohnsitz hat wie
kann das rechtlich überhaupt zustande
kommen ja grundsätzlich ist es natürlich
eine einfache frage wie so vieles in der
juristerei
aber wir haben auf der anderen seite
eine komplizierte antwort auf diese
einfache frage weil um sich mal von
diesem einzelfall zu lösen den wir jetzt
hier gerade besprechen diesen tragischen
einzelfall
wir haben einen haftbefehl und nach
befehl bedeutet dass jemandem seine
freiheit geraubt wird ein
schwerwiegender grundrechtseingriff und
damit dieser grundrechtseingriff
gerechtfertigt wird brauchen wir
einerseits einen dringenden tatverdacht
und andererseits haftgründe dringender
tatverdacht bedeutet also es muss sehr
wahrscheinlich sein dass etwas passiert
ist und haftgründe sind in der
strafprozessordnung normiert und da gibt
es unter anderem auch den haftgrund der
fluchtgefahr und fluchtgefahr bedeutet
dass das gericht die oder die
ermittlungsbehörde angst hat dass sich
der tatverdächtige dem verfahren
entziehen könnte er könnte ins ausland
weg gehen und nicht mehr greifbar sein
und das wäre ein grund jemanden in
untersuchungshaft zu stecken wäre es
dann kein haftgrund wenn
wiederholungsgefahr besteht in diesem
fall dann tragischerweise tatsächlich
nach nicht mal zwei wochen der fall war
wiederholungsgefahr ist natürlich auch
ein haftgrund
und bei der wiederholungsgefahr gibt es
katalog taten die nennen sich so
bestimmte taten unter denen das nur
anwendung findet da ist der schwere
sexuelle missbrauch von kindern auch
drin
die wiederholungsgefahr hat anscheinend
das gericht bei der haftprüfung die
durchgeführt worden ist nicht gesehen
nicht erfüllt gesehen das ist immer eine
prognoseentscheidung am ende des tages
leider wurde hier anscheinend es ist ein
mutmaßlicher täter die schuld wird wie
gesagt erst am ende festgestellt
aber anscheinend ist hier leider eine
prognoseentscheidung getroffen worden
die zum jetzigen stand gegebenenfalls
nicht die richtige war
das wissen wir aber noch nicht das
werden wir erst am ende sehen aber
natürlich der pädagoge fall ist auch ein
haftgrund im gegensatz zu den anderen
haftgründen wo wir immer nur das
vergangene betrachten ob da was passiert
ist und dafür möchten wir jemanden
bestrafen ist die wiederholungsgefahr
etwas was nach vorne schauen wir wollen
die gesellschaft schützen vor einem
mutmaßlichen täter das wieder schwere
verbrechen nicht stattfinden
und jetzt mit den informationen die wir
heute haben ist man natürlich leider
wesentlich schlauer als man das vor 14
tagen eventuell gewesen ist
also kann man zumindest sicher sagen
dass der mutmassliche täter jetzt in
untersuchungshaft untersuchungshaft
bleibt bis beide taten aufgeklärt sind
um das klarzustellen ich bin nicht der
verteidiger in diesem fall ich habe nur
diese informationen die mir aus der
presse bekannt sind
aber ich gehe fest davon aus dass sein
untersuchungshaft jetzt bleibt auch die
fluchtgefahr ist natürlich bei jemandem
der aus dem ausland kommt und
insbesondere aus nicht eu ausland kommt
auch bei einem festen wohnsitz immer
gleich zu beginn fürs gericht weil das
gericht das kenne ich einfach aus meiner
praxis erfahrung sagt immer ja er zwei
festen wohnsitz hier in deutschland
könnte ein asylheim sein könnte eine
richtige wohnung sein was auch immer
aber da sind natürlich keine festen
sozialen bindungen in deutschland haben
ihre strukturen sind nicht vorhanden
daher ist der drang ins ausland zu
fliehen immer gegeben wieso es hier in
diesem fall so entschieden wurde
wie gesagt das wird sich später bei der
öffentlichen hauptverhandlung nicht sein